how's it going everybody it's Warren
there's a big exciting rumor going
around right now that Keanu Reeves could
finally be making his way to the MCU
which doesn't come as that big of a
surprise because Kevin Feige the
president of Marvel Studios has already
confirmed with all of these rumors going
around about Keanu Reeves entry and the
MCU yes Marvel Studios has talked to
Keanu Reeves about multiple roles that
he could play in the MCU they're just
waiting on the perfect role and they
haven't found it yet there's also
reports that Mark Ruffalo and the Hulk
could return for Thor at love and
thunder which makes sense because he was
in Thor Ragnarok he was a big part of it
it was basically a Thor and Hulk movie
because before Marvel Studios didn't
have the rights to do a solo hulk film
there are now reports saying that Marvel
does have those rights kin but before
they didn't so that's why he was in for
love and thunder and all these crossover
films so it makes sense that he would
return for Thor at love and thunder
since he was such a big part of the last
one and not to mention that Mark Ruffalo
has already confirmed that he's met with
Kevin Feige and plans on meeting with
him again to discuss the future for the
Hulk and he said that he has a lot of
great ideas so let's talk about this
rumor of Keanu Reeves finally entering
the MCU as silver surfer and in Thor
love and thunder nonetheless be sure to
subscribe with notifications turned on
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and I'm also giving
away an xbox one and ps4 so be sure to
subscribe like and comment on the video
so you can enter so there is a pretty
big reason why a lot of people think
that Keanu Reeves is going to be playing
the Silver Surfer and Thor love and
thunder and why this rumor is going
around right now this all started with
fandoms wiki page for Thor love and
thunder on this page it lists things
that are rumored and it lists things
that are confirmed and one thing that it
lists under cast is that Keanu Reeves
will have a role now this is not listed
under the confirmed section however
there's a big reason why people are
giving this validity right now yesterday
it was revealed by an exclusive from
Collider that Christian Bale the former
Batman actor is officially in talks with
Marvel to play a role in Thor love and
thunder and what's really interesting
about this fandom wikipage is that it
actually listed Christian Bale under the
cast it said he will appear before this
exclusive announcement came out
yesterday and then we go under
characters and it says that Loki will
appear Hulk will appear it's confirmed
that Valkyrie will appear Lady SIF will
appear then it says gore the god butcher
will appear
beta ray bill will
here and the Silver Surfer will appear
now since the report came out that
Christian Bale is in talks with Marvel
Studios to play a role in Thor love and
thunder we've had a few reports come out
to say that the role that he's in talks
to play is beta ray bill which makes
perfect sense because there were Easter
eggs for beta ray bill in the last Thor
Thor Ragnarok not to mention there was
Easter eggs for beta ray bill and
Avengers in game so if Christian Bale is
in talks to play beta ray bill who is
Keanu Reeves and talks to play well the
Silver Surfer rumor has actually been
going on for some time now and the role
that makes the most sense for him to
play in Thor love and thunder is the
Silver Surfer it makes more sense than
beta ray bill or Gore the butcher and
there's plenty of reasons why and let's
start with what Kevin Feige has
personally said about Keanu Reeves in
the MCU in an interview with comic book
calm Brandon Davis who works for a comic
book calm asked Kevin Feige the
following a couple of actors I want to
ask you about Keanu Reeves you guys
talking to him for anything in which
Kevin Feige replied we talked to him for
almost every film we make every film we
make we talked to Keanu Reeves about I
don't know when if or ever he'll join
the MCU but we very much want to figure
out the right way to do it
Kevin Feige then went on to talk about
how this situation is the exact same
situation that they were in with Jake
Gyllenhaal for spider-man far from home
they wanted Jake Gyllenhaal in the MCU
they talked to him many times about
multiple different roles they just never
found the perfect role for him until
Mysterio came up in spider-man far from
home and that was the role that they
knew he would do a good job at so Kevin
Feige wants Keanu Reeves in the MCU and
the Silver Surfer would be a perfect
role for him we know that Thor Love and
thunder is going to be a space film it's
going to be set in the cosmos and it
seems like a lot of characters are set
to appear in this movie which makes
sense if they're going to be exploring
the galaxy and actually it's already
been stated by Kevin Feige that
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 with James
Gunn and Thor love and thunder are
supposed to lead the MCU into the cosmic
feature exploring vast different parts
that we haven't seen yet and this was
said a while ago and has been confirmed
for a while and in Thor love and thunder
we actually are going to have both Thor
and the guardians of the galaxy in one
movie at the end of Avengers in game 4
left with the guardians of the galaxy
and II said I don't really know where
I'm gonna go but I have a ride Taika
Waititi the director for Thor 11 thunder
already confirmed that Thor love and
thunder is going to be bigger bolder and
brighter than Thor Ragnarok which is
something to say about the film because
it was already pretty crazy and if the
rumor for Thor love and thunder ends up
being true then the guardians and Thor
or just Thor is going to end up running
into beta ray bill and the Silver Surfer
at some point in time in the movie and
Marvel wants to cast Keanu Reeves but
they want to cast him in a character
that could stay for a pretty long time
especially if you're dealing with
somebody like Keanu Reeves you don't
want him to just appear in one MCU movie
and then leave Marvel has consistently
done that in the past they've introduced
a character or an actor into one movie
just to have that actor or character be
done after only one movie and fans have
hated this if you look at Ultron and you
look at Red Skull these are major
villains that should still be in the MCU
but for love and thunder is the perfect
opportunity to introduce Keanu Reeves
into the MCU as the Silver Surfer
because Keanu Reeves has two major films
coming out months before Thor love and
thunders release Keanu Reeves is going
to be in the matrix for Andy's going to
be in John wick for and these both come
out on May 21st of 2021 then Thor love
and thunder is going to come out on
November 5th of 2021 not even five
months away everybody already loves
Keanu Reeves but the hype free Keanu
Reeves is going to be absolutely insane
after these two movies come out
especially since they are coming out on
this same day it would be a brilliant
move by Marvel Studios to have Keanu
Reeves appear as a major character such
as the Silver Surfer in Thor 11th under
only five months after all of this hype
is at its all-time high John wick 1 2 &
3 were major successes critics and fans
raved about these films and the first
three Matrix movies are considered some
of the greatest films ever but there
hasn't been a Matrix film since 2003
that was 17 years ago and when the
matrix 4 comes out that's going to be 18
years ago so people are going to be
flooding to the box office to see the
new Matrix movie and to see the new John
wick movie and they're going to
absolutely love Keanu Reeves because
it's Keanu Reeves everybody loves him so
if they want to cash in on the hype of
Keanu Reeves this would be the perfect
time to put him in a movie and the
perfect character for him to play
and another reason that the Silver
Surfer is perfect for him the play is
because we know the Silver Surfer is
going to be in the MCU for a very long
time and not to mention fans are already
on the edge of their seats wondering win
these new Fox characters that Disney and
Marvel Studios now have are going to
enter the MCU and who is going to play
them the hype is going to be absolutely
ridiculous when we finally see one of
those characters enter the MCU
but having Keanu Reeves play the Silver
Surfer means that he'll probably be in
the MCU for at least ten years and that
reason is because of Galactus it's
pretty much all but confirmed there's
been reports from many different
credible sources that Galactus is in
fact going to be the next big bad
villain in fact there have been reports
that we could even begin to hear about
Galactus as early on as the Eternals and
again you've heard me say this before
but the future of the MCU is going to
have two main villains a cosmic one and
an earthbound one Galactus is going to
be the cosmic one and Thor and the
guardians are heading into the cosmos so
it's only a matter of time until they
run into a Herald of Galactus and again
according to the rumors The Herald of
Galactus that they're going to be
running into and Thor love and thunder
is going to be the Silver Surfer now a
lot of people think that Keanu Reeves
would make an excellent Doctor Doom
which I definitely agree however I think
he would make a better Silver Surfer and
I think that Marvel Studios probably
thinks that as well and this comes down
to his actual demeanor as a person in
real life he's a very quiet and gentle
and compassionate person but at the same
time he can be insanely intense like we
see in the John wick films which is
really perfect for the Silver Surfer
because that's how the Silver Surfer
truly is on the inside as Norman rad
Norman rad became the Silver Surfer by
sacrificing himself he volunteered to be
The Herald of Galactus in order to save
his home planet from Galactus devouring
it so he became the Silver Surfer out of
compassion and love for his people he
served as a Herald of Galactus finding
planets for Galactus to eat and then he
went to earth once he was on earth the
Fantastic Four helped him rediscover his
nobility and his compassion towards
people and he ended up saving the earth
he stopped Galactus from destroying the
planet but was then exiled there as a
punishment so again that demeanor and
the spirit of the Silver Surfer is
pretty close to the actual spirit and
demeanor
Keanu Reeves in real life making him the
perfect candidate for this role and not
to mention it said that the Hulk is
going to be returning for Thor love and
thunder as well and if we listen to
everything that's been happening between
Kevin Feige and Mark Ruffalo recently
this seems pretty likely and he did say
hey do you think there's any more story
left here and I said I can probably come
up with a few storylines especially
since the Hulk was such a big part in
the first movie and an Avengers in game
he really helped out for as well so if
we have a movie with Thor the guardians
of the galaxy for a part of it The Hulk
beta ray bill and the Silver Surfer this
movie is going to be absolutely insane
but that's supposedly what it's supposed
to be Taika Waititi said it's going to
be absolutely insane which is something
that I'm honestly really excited about
so although this is just a rumor for now
nothing is confirmed I would love to see
Keanu Reeves play the Silver Surfer in
Thor 11 thunder and in the MCU so let me
know if you would like this to happen
would you like Keanu Reeves to play the
Silver Surfer people have been fan
casting Keanu Reeves for a very long
time would you like to see him in this
role let me know in the comments down
below and again don't forget to
subscribe when notifications turned on
so you don't miss anything relating to
the MCU and don't forget to like the
video and comment below to enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 winner gets to choose at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
don't forget to follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof